jesse smellette will soon be a free man
uh court has agreed that he is uh uh
that he should be released why because
he's appealing
and he would be in jail well uh he would
get out of jail actually after the
appeals process ended so it all seems
all just so silly but uh this is the
reality we live in we also have this blm
activist who's been indicted on 18
different felony charges for fraud along
with her husband so we'll talk about
that disney workers are going to be
protesting the parental rights and
education bill which makes no sense as
it turns out the majority of americans
actually support the content uh the core
of this bill of course we also have
stuff happening in ukraine so we'll be
talking about that as well unfortunately
tonight ian is sick and will not be
joining joining us but joining us to
talk about this and much more is terry
schilling you want to introduce yourself
yeah thanks so much for having me tim um
terry schilling president of american
principles project we are the nra but
for families so we don't do guns we do
families uh we helped start the
anti-transgender sports fight we we
started spending a lot of money on
campaign ads
attacking politicians who were wanting
to put boys in girls sports and what do
you know the american people are against
that uh in a in a big way and so
we've uh been working in the states
we've passed uh anti i'm sorry women's
pro women's sports legislation in 11
states now i was the most recent one and
now that fight's kind of evolving um
into something even bigger so it's
really happy um it's really necessary
and um we're really cool we'll talk
about that stuff too along with
everything else we got sheamus yeah very
excited to be here i think it's gonna be
a great conversation an nra for families
this uh yeah this this idea that we
would actually have um a lobby for the
family which is the building block of
society unbelievable that that's so
novel to us but thank you for the work
you're doing i'm interested in asking
you some questions about it my name is
seamus coughlin i have a youtube channel
called freedom tunes we animate uh
educational cartoons and political
satire every thursday we have a cartoon
coming out tomorrow about how
basically the industrial military
complex is constantly trying to use
world war ii nostalgia to get us
involved in new conflicts i think it's
uh pretty funny and you guys will like
it so go over there subscribe hit the
notification bell and we'll have that up
tomorrow and i am no excuse for ian we
will miss his input definitely for sure
um we'll just carry on in his memory and
i'll try to come up with something wild
and crazy in the meantime before we get
started my friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com to get your
supply of keto elevate from biotrust
this is their
c8mct oil powder this stuff's fantastic
it gives you sustained energy for mental
clarity increased energy and appetite
management you mix it i like mixing in
my coffee mixes right in adds like a
creamy texture to it again
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you will get
51 percent off as well as a 60 day money
back guarantee keto elevate provides
your body only ca to the most ketogenic
mct so you will get energy levels high
energy levels healthy habitat management
mental clarity and focus athletic
performance you'll get free shipping on
every order and for every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you'll get free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust's team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order again
at
eatrightandfeelwell.com special thanks
to biotrust and don't forget head over
to timcast.com become a member if you'd
like to support us directly as a member
you are keeping all of our journalists
gainfully employed and they are all very
happy that you're doing so but you'll
also get access to exclusive segments
from this show around 11 or so p.m
tonight we'll we will be publishing a
members only podcast segment of this
show it's usually about a half an hour
long and uh it's kind of it's kind of
the uncensored show we do swear a lot
it's the non-family friendly show so
definitely check that out if you would
like to support our work but don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
right now if you can if you take the url
just post it wherever you can to really
really help us out
now let's jump into that first story
breaking news
court orders jesse smallette released
from jail during his appeal after just
six days in prison disgraced empire
actor justice malet will be released
after serving just six days judges sided
with his lawyers who argued that he
would be finished with his sentence
before the appeals process was complete
he was sentenced to 150 days after being
convicted of five felony counts of
disorderly conduct for falsely reporting
a racist and homophobic attack in 2019
smollett could have served just 75 days
with good behavior he had been kept in
psychiatric care in a restraint bed in
the cook county jail yikes man so as
many of you are probably aware he
started yelling i'm not suicidal over
and over again which made many of us
believe that he was
and we did mention this briefly on the
show we mentioned it last time a little
bit
my view and i think this is what you're
saying we agree
he was actually suicidal and by saying
he wasn't
he was hoping that people would think it
was a conspiracy because i got to be
honest his life's over it's been over
he's a joke well that's what i said on
air a couple days ago when we first
talked about the story granted it's just
speculation we have no idea what his
motives are but it sounded to me like it
was at least possible that this is
something a person who's planning on
killing themselves would say if they
were a complete egomaniac who wanted
people to think that there was some kind
of conspiracy behind it you know there's
something sociopathic about this guy i
mean when you have someone that's able
to literally like cry on demand and go
into great detail about the entire hoax
um and i you know i think this is really
tragic this whole news story right
because it's it's setting an example the
whole point of punishing these people is
to show society what happens when you do
something like this and so he gets out
of jail now after six days there's going
to be a lot more hoaxes and i think that
that might actually be deliberate on the
left's part right like they they don't
want these hoaxes to go away there was a
tweet
from i think was matt walsh
and he had a bunch of tweets from like
him and andy know and he was basically
saying
that he he couldn't you know in almost
every circumstance these these hate
crimes where someone spray paint
something they turn out to be hoaxes
and then he shows this uh story in four
parts you know quote tweets from andy
know him and some other person
and you know he says i can't recall a
single moment maybe andy knows that this
in recent memory of one of these turning
out to be real someone responded with
you should pay attention because this
happened at emery and then posts a link
and then andy noah is like the guy who
did that was a black the guy who wrote
the graffiti and the racial slurs was
actually a black guy yep so i got to be
honest
yeah the only the only instance i can
think of that was was not
a hoax was like some kids in new york
used sidewalk chalk and made swastikas
and that was it
and it was like some little kids so
there was no real like direct attack on
an in a on a store or a person
i'm like no i think that one was like
actually maybe i'm wrong about that but
there was that story i remember that
that was a former nfl player had a a
pizza shop and like a chicken shop and
then they were they were doing really
bad so he just ransacked them and spray
painted racial slurs and then you know
it happens and the thing about these
little kids i remember in high school
my friends would prank me by drawing
swastikas on my notebook i'm not kidding
like it was like
yeah and we had this whole thing of like
edgy oh just just uh turn it into
windows right so like
little kids can't comprehend nazism
really like it they they don't
understand the gravity of the holocaust
and how terrible it was and so like they
prank each other with that and that's
it's usually either a really terrible
prank from someone that's super immature
or a total hoax where someone's trying
to get more attention or get away with
fraud i think it's people just trying to
get attention there was how many
churches have been vandalized i mean
you've probably seen these stories right
yeah they'll put racial slurs in the
parking lot and then it was just like
it was it was someone from the church
like staging a hoax yeah no i mean it's
disgusting stuff i'm sure a couple years
ago you guys remember there was this
story at mizzou and within one of the
bathroom stalls someone had drawn a
swastika using fecal matter
and we were told that this was a
neo-nazi attack instead of first of all
extremely um unbalanced mentally ill
person to draw anything with fecal
matter but somebody who's actually a
nazi is not going to depict their like
sacred cherished symbol with human crap
right right
but the conclusion oh my goodness this
is a hate crime it was very bizarre
instead of like wow what a bizarre
disgusting thing to do it was this is
white supremacy you know it's hard
sometimes waking up and being like oh
that's the news again
because it keeps happening yeah with
these stories and and it's it's
remarkable that
you know what really is just it's kind
of depressing jesse smellette's being
released you know we thought we got him
hmm we got him he was he was arrested he
was caught we knew it he goes through
trial he is mocked and ridiculed more
evidence comes out it seems like a
clear-cut slam dunk case finally
convicted then we await sentence
sentencing and we're like please just
for once lock one of these people up and
they're like okay
you let them out six days later well
what are you what are you taking out
what are you offering odds on that he
gets another like a another acting gig
hollywood's going to take him back i i
mean i i would take so i would take
one-to-one odds on that really
definitely i wouldn't be sure one to one
odds yeah or i
one to one i would take one to one odds
that that he gets some type of
new tv deal or or
music he'll he'll come and repair his
image this is what they do he'll have a
whole apology tour right he'll come out
and say he was sorry he realized what he
did and how bad it was and then he
starts making millions again doesn't one
to one mean that you'd put up money and
win nothing if you were right no no i
mean a dollar for a dollar right so i uh
plus 100 so it's two to one doesn't it
no no two to one is i put up a dollar
and if i win you pay me two bucks is
that what it is yeah sure
okay i don't know yeah i think you're
right sorry yeah maybe i haven't been in
the casino in long enough it's been
actually a couple weeks
yeah so you think so you think so i kind
of thought his career was over i mean
he's a laughingstock
in a non-clown world i think i think
it's over but we live in clown world
that's why i mean also um so i'm not
sure if you guys are familiar with brian
peck but he was convicted i believe of
raping a child and he was brought back
to work at disney after he served his
sentence so
um oh no i'm sorry so yeah abc slash
disney hires convicted child molester
brian peck who worked on children's tv
show
one year after he's released from prison
so the idea that they're above hiring
jesse smallett is yeah that's true and
they gave you know um was it roman
polanski oh yeah
yeah and who's the other guy who's the
other guy what's his face
the newer guy right who is joking about
pedophilia on twitter no no no no no the
other guy with the glasses oh i can't
remember what's his name he's a famous
famous guy famous guy with glasses i got
nothing sorry director producer or
whatever steven spielberg no no
i don't know enough about movies and
stuff yeah
yeah i don't know but yeah like with
whoopi goldberg they brought her right
back and i'm still flabbergasted by the
fact that andrew gillum is still a name
in political circles after what happened
with him absolutely is he really he's
still around yeah he's rehabbing his
image he's repairing his marriage after
that that's why that's why sometimes
that's why i say like i wake up and i
see the news and i'm just like how about
we go and talk about
you know a donut factory instead because
it's it's just i'm sick of how do people
believe this stuff at this point how do
we how do we sit back and allow these
kind of things to happen and
you know it's just kind of mind-numbing
yeah well you know ian mentioned this
the other day that i had said to him the
way i define elite is as a person who's
never going to face any consequences for
their actions and we see that in the
case of jesse smalling he was sentenced
but then he's let go after serving six
days so honestly i guess those are more
harsh consequences than a lot of other
people we would consider elite would
ever end up facing but we shouldn't be
surprised that he's let go because what
he did
was try to forward the narrative that
they're constantly trying to promote in
the media woody allen racist woody allen
didn't he do something with his sis or a
daughter or something there was
something really screwed up with him
yeah yeah people are mentioning james
gunn too yeah but yeah but james gunn
was was trying to be an edge lord and
failing
he thought he was posting you know
obscene jokes about children would be
funny and people were like bro that's
gross stuff don't do that so that's it's
it's different if you if you think
you're being edgy you know and it's not
and it's bad like i'll be like bro that
was bad don't do it again i think that's
right but you know like roman and woody
and justin
yeah yeah that's kind of like yo those
people shouldn't be welcomed back in
this place yeah that's cancelled culture
justice mullet should be canceled
exactly this is hilarious because every
single time anyone on the right points
out that a person has done something
terrible the left goes
i thought you were against cancel
culture as if that's any kind of point
against our argument that you shouldn't
comb through someone's tweets from 12
years ago and then try to cancel them
because they said men are men
[Laughter]
that race car driver's dad who said the
edward in the 80s and so sponsors
canceled him that's so insane some
things should be canceled right like
there's a reason why we have laws in
prison and like something should have a
stigma to them yeah but i think the
problem is it always comes back to this
one issue where it's just you know
institutions and even conservatives take
these people seriously
and i'm just like
why
stop contracting with them stop working
with them stop servicing them stop
hiring them stop being hired by them
just tell these unserious people to go
away like if i out there there was a
comic book store like a game shop and i
see the big blm fist i keep walking yeah
and i'm like i look up on google and
it's like we sell magic the gathering
cards and comic books i'm like i'm gonna
go check it out and i show up and they
see a big sign in the window and i just
turn right back around get my car and
leave yep i'll order it online dude i'm
not going to give any service to these
unserious psychotic occultists just just
not no i'm sorry these are the these
people are the reason justice mullet
gets away with this right these are the
people who cheered for every single hoax
every time
they always fall for it and it's it's
not even they're falling forward no no
it's part of the plan right well no no
they continue continue but i have a
point i want to make about falling for
it no i just think it's part of their
plan they want division they want chaos
they they don't they want us
withdrawing from society and not
participating right and and i think that
it's really important not to fall trap
to that but also to figure out how to
not support them and give them
legitimacy yeah so it's interesting
because i think you're right that they
don't fall for it because to them it
does not matter whether something is
true or false what matters is whether it
maps under their ideological worldview
because then in some subjective sense
it's poetically true so it's okay for
them to promote it and it forwards their
goal which is overall good and noble the
people who fall for it are the
conservatives who don't immediately say
this sounds ridiculous and it's probably
bs because we're afraid that there's
some slight possibility that it's a true
story and we don't want to be labeled
racist the one time it may have actually
happened you know what i think
i i actually
i agree with you
i don't know if jesse smollette is going
to get work right so so they're going to
let him out of jail maybe his appeal
just fails then he goes back to jail
they're saying it's only going to be 75
days so you know two and a half months
with good behavior
i don't know if he gets rehired to act
but
i would actually be willing to bet
that he would get a reality tv show oh
yeah following the
saga i mean it's
people will watch it or not why not a
cnn gig right
i mean that's how
fundamentally unserious those networks
are yeah i don't know about cnn i think
it would be interesting to see them
bring him on because he's friends with
don lemon but they they they you know
cnn as bad as they are they don't want
to you know punch holes purposefully in
their ship if it sinks well here's the
thing but hold on look you know what a
and e or amc or whatever what's the
channel that is the weird a e a and e
yeah yeah they're gonna be like justice
millett reality show and it's gonna be
him sitting down and be like i didn't do
this i gotta call my lawyer and they're
gonna follow him around people would
watch that because they hate him so so
that's his opportunity and he's gonna
i just book
he's going to go find the real hoaxer
yeah
i think that you guys are
underestimating how good of an actor
jesse is he's just going to slip
jesse i'm sorry he's gonna slip into a
new life somewhere become a different
person and he's just gonna blend in
wherever he is because he's so talented
that way and then there's gonna be some
beloved celebrity 20 years from now who
everyone worships and he's gonna go it
was i all along jesse and i fooled you
with my incredible acting skills isn't
it crazy though i mean look at when he
went on was it abc
how he was it abc did yeah 60 minutes or
something 60 minutes he manufactures
perfectly these these tiers yes this
performance well that's what i'm saying
he is one of the greatest actors of all
time of all time yeah that was the whole
thing
i mean this the whole thing was a demo
tape for him he comes out and he's like
i want to admit that i staged the whole
thing and the court the trial that was
the performance that was the problem
i'll be in jail i'll be out in two
months
call my agent very avant-garde piece of
art do you remember when walking phoenix
did that thing no he like quit acting
and then started rapping and everyone
was like what is he doing what's
happening and then it turned out that it
was a big stunt yep i remember that
that's that's probably just a smell
that's best bet it was it was a big stun
i was just joshing you guys i was
trashing around all right i was like
he'd probably go to jail for a lot
longer if he said that
because right imagine i mean i don't
think so i don't i don't think he's ever
gonna see prison time no i think
actually if he admitted that he did it
and it was a hoax and he did it for
acting he'd get less time he'd get an
oscar he would get no he would get less
time in jail because he's only he's
getting 150 days
even though he's refusing to admit what
he did was wrong yeah he's still denying
it so they're you know they're giving
him that penalty the idea is there's
something called the trial text you go
to trial you get a harsher penalty
because the idea is the idea is really
that you're wasting the courts times
they punish you but the idea is supposed
to be that you haven't learned your
lesson so you need more time in jail
well and then to put it cynically the
other idea is if we make people feel
more afraid to go to trial then we can
just sentence people for crimes without
actually giving them their day in court
yeah so they'll they'll pick him back up
maybe yeah i mean at the very least it's
not something we would ever put past
them
but oh man yeah isn't it depressing
though
i guess
if you ever had any hope in hollywood i
suppose or the legal system
that's fair that's fair oh man but it's
also chicago i mean i'm oh yeah that's
fair i'm from illinois so it's
yeah it's tough as are we it is yeah
yeah
yeah yeah would it be just it would just
be so funny if it turns out that this
really did happen and the cops staged
all the evidence to like
you know just make him look bad it's
like the worst white supremacist hate
crime that's ever taken turns out that
the two white dudes who attacked jesse
were actually like off-duty cops goes
all the way up to trump even higher goes
all the way up to putin and it actually
is a country and we just we're making
fun of this poor guy no one no one tells
you this but cook county very red
very very incredibly red yeah yeah deep
red county yeah it's just a city right
extremely red no it's a little bit
outside of the city some of the suburbs
or cook county well illinois itself is
red yeah just you go in chicago well who
is it that said there are no uh there
are no
red or no blue states only blue cities
yeah
that's right that's true and there are
red cities which is interesting but the
interesting thing about chicago is that
it's not even blue
it's
zombie
you you have like illinois growing up in
chicago you have the zombie contingent
and the republican contingent and
republicans you know they can vary from
very ignorant to very knowledgeable
but the the people in the cities who are
voting democrat are the zombie
contingent 99
and that's that's what i grew up around
people who are just like vote blue no
matter who and i'm like who are you
voting for don't no don't care as long
as as long as not a republican i'm like
the city has been run by democrats for
80 plus years and it's worse than ever
no it's doing really well just worse
than ever
and it's funny too because we used to
have uh do you guys know what lotus
it's like someone
on the south side of chicago oh these
guys pull up with carts full of corn
oh
yeah they'll take the corn
and they put mayonnaise parmesan and
cayenne pepper on it and you eat it so
good or i would always have them they
would they cut the corn off into a cup
and mix it with mayonnaise parmesan and
cayenne
they got banned in our neighborhood
terrible but only like they couldn't
cross cicero on the south side because
when you cross so this is the
fascinating thing about the midway area
from like harlem to cicero which is a
few miles from 47th like 63rd was a
generally white polish immigrant and
like whiter area when you crossed 47th
to the north side it was all black uh
community all black housing when you
cross cicero became all like latino
so the city for some reason banned the
elotes guys from coming into our
neighborhood but they could still like
they couldn't cross cicero and that was
the weirdest thing to us because we were
like so the guys who sell corn who are
hispanic can stay in the hispanic
neighborhood but we like the corn we
love those guys they took it away from
us
it's almost like they wanted the
segregation yes and here's what the
funny thing is like there are certain
things that like break down cultural
divides right like it's food it's music
it's uh you know movies uh literature
and and i do think there's something to
that like this whole like anti-cultural
appropriation thing is really meant to
keep us from participating in other
cultures and being open to it and and
breaking down those barriers like cinco
de mayo is a great holiday because
everyone likes tacos and it's not like
denigrating to like the mexican
community to celebrate cinco de mayo
like it's a good thing to participate
catholics are really good about this
right like we take over and baptize all
these like pagan holidays and make them
ours and it's it's beautiful it's it's
that's that's colonization we're not
giving them back
ever
ever you guys not even christian trees
that's what we're told not even
christmas which i didn't know i've had
people tell me that they're like you
know when you worship easter you're
worshiping your fertility god it's like
i didn't know that
interesting i didn't know that i guess
well but i guess you know better than me
what i'm doing
you didn't realize that you were you you
didn't catch yourself when you were
praying that you were actually saying
the fertility goddess i know it's
but yeah no it's uh it's true that there
are a lot of things from other cultures
that can be sanctified and people from
different cultures are able to relate to
each other
and part of the problem is because
racial tensions are so high and we have
really stoked the flames of genuine
hatred along ethnic lines people are
afraid not only to participate in other
people's cultures but to even engage in
humor that might be targeted towards
other groups even in a more playful way
and i find it interesting because i
think you see this happen sometimes
every now and again you'll meet that
couple
who make jokes about each other but you
can tell it's in like kind of a stabby
sort of way they're really being
sort of uh crass and snide to each other
and it's very painful for everyone who's
there but then you have some couples who
can kind of poke fun at each other and
it's really funny and everyone enjoys it
i think what happens is as a
relationship between two people or a
group of people breaks down humor goes
from something which can be cherished
and which is very endearing and helps
bring them together and it turns into
something really insulting and the same
exact joke can be really funny coming
from a person who you have a good
relationship with or really uh offensive
coming from someone who you don't and so
i think i think uh breaking down racial
relations people ask why everything's so
pc i think a huge part of it is we just
don't trust each other
i was just thinking you know about the
cultural appropriation stuff and the
protests remember that video where the
the girl at prom or whatever she wore
the the um chinese dress yeah
what is it called kimono no that's
japanese
it was called it was chinese thing and
um people in the chat will tell us what
it was called so i'm i'm forgetting and
then people in china were like that's
cool like they actually really liked it
and i thought about i was thinking about
this there's also the video where the
guy's got dreads and the black girl like
literally grabs him and she's like
you're stealing my culture and he's like
what are you talking about and then i'm
like how come these people never protest
taco bell
yeah why don't they show up to panda
express well also as if like there's one
ethnic group that just owns dreadlocks
right that's not true though i mean the
vikings had it yeah exactly that's why
and and you know i know a bunch of
people in scandinavian countries who
have dreadlocks because of like they had
dreadlocks but it's like people have
hair dude right people can do what they
want to their hair
hairstyles no that's arduou
like intellectual properties yo taco
bell
bears no resemblance to actual mexican
food that's exactly right hard shell
tacos burritos burritos aren't a mexican
thing
and and and cheddar cheese what's going
on here that nacho cheese is not cheese
it's powdered cheese
uh panda express now i'll tell you taco
bell is delicious it's almost worth the
bottle obstruction
and express is also delicious but man
they're just chunks of sugary fried
chicken and it's yes but it's good but
i'm not going to pretend it's actually
chinese food
you know thai food in this country is a
sugary fatty
americanized version the same thing with
like all of these different foods and
you know what people love it right yeah
so if these people want to go oh i'm i
cultural corporation is wrong stop
ordering pad thai on grubhub i know
you're doing it because it's like the
number one food on grub up or it's in
the top five or whatever pizza it's
italian what gives you the right
no one's protesting these things you
know what you ever noticed that
no one ever
starts an irish food chain like an irish
food
that's not like a large national thing
you know you don't have it and every you
don't have a bunch of them in every
single city we have scottish we wish
some people would appropriate that part
of honestly no i'm glad that we have
you why don't you make oh donald's no
donald
mcdonald's it's an irish name you go in
there it's got irish food no it's mc
it's when it's mac it's scottish uh when
i went to the uk they told me it was
scottish what did those brits say to you
yeah they were gonna tell you more
colonizer lies about ireland and you're
gonna believe that bro are you serious
look it up i think you're wrong oh maybe
i hope not because if we lose mcdonald's
we have nothing left
in the united states
i often have like a stupid dad joke
where i tell people like what do you
want to get i'll be like do you guys
want to get irish food like oh yeah
there's a good place to make um
mcdonald's and everyone laughs i did
that in the uk and they looked at me and
they were like that's scottish and i was
like no no it's mc and they're like o is
irish mc is scottish and i was like is
it that's not true no mc is is irish
mcnamara is my mother's maiden name and
they're all from ireland yeah yeah yeah
they were like
those lie to you yeah of course they did
all right well let's talk about the next
lie oh boy we had the story from the new
york post
boston social justice activist and
husband scammed at least a hundred and
eighty five thousand dollars from donors
so saith the feds they're being hit with
i think it's 18 different uh
uh charges federal charges they say a
high-profile social justice activist in
boston and her husband used a non-profit
they founded uh to scam at least 185
thousand dollars from donors who
included a black lives matter chapter
and the local da's office federal
authorities alleged monica cannon grant
and clark grant allegedly treated their
violence in boston organization as a
personal piggy bank to pay for rent
shopping sprees delivery meals visit to
a nail salon summer vacation trip to
maryland i heard that they were going to
bubble gum shrimp that was one of the
things that was that was heavily
reported they're going to mention the
following year she was named best social
justice advocate by boston magazine and
one of the boston globes bostonians of
the year
when will people stop falling for this
stuff should we want to the list again
should we run through the list the
trayvon martin martin story what was the
initial report that a white guy
saw a black kid and then attacked him
and killed him shot him what really
happened trayvon martin and george got
into a fight maybe one was maybe
zimmerman was in the wrong for
confronting him he was a neighborhood
watch and trayvon martin was walking
behind houses trayvon martin had him in
a ground pound position where he was on
top of him and pummeling him and then
george him and shot him in the chest and
killed him zimmerman's hispanic we also
have michael brown hands up don't shoot
that was a lie that was total total loss
so remember the trayvon case nbc
actually deceptively edited the phone
call in order to make it sound like
zimmerman was describing trayvon martin
as being up to no good because he was
quote unquote black they asked him what
does he look like he says he looks like
he's up to no good uh he's wearing a
black hoodie something along those lines
and they cut it together to say he looks
like he's up to no good black well the
other thing is the whole thing was a
sham with trayvon martin the the picture
that you saw everywhere was him when he
was like 11 or 12. right and he was much
much older and much much bigger they
made it out like george zimmerman like
beat up like a 12 year old little punk
kid and he was much older than that
jesse's millet
lie
on an arbory story he was just jogging
that was a lie
it's just every single day there's a new
lie and these people they're rittenhouse
yeah the whole thing the the entire
thing was that oh he crossed state lines
and you shouldn't have that gun as soon
as i saw the story it was very obvious
to me and i think everyone who saw that
this was a case of self-defense but then
they started mutting the waters by
saying he had broken gun laws or across
state lines and maybe he was looking for
trouble but not only could none of that
be substantiated i'm pretty sure they
just made all of it up because it was so
obvious that this kid was defending
himself and then what ends up happening
is people go well because they've
muddied the waters now we have to wait
for more answers before we can really be
sure and take a side and the story loses
momentum at a certain point i just you
know i i every every few months i say
something where i'm just like
it's all the same thing every day
we wake up we have a new story because
i've been i've been you know talking
about these stories and criticizing the
hoaxes
going on seven or so years now
um a little bit longer but doing the
actual youtube stuff and the podcast
stuff and at a certain point i'm kind of
just like
what's the point of saying it if it
doesn't change anything no no i think
that's the wrong mentality i i wouldn't
lose hope there are a lot of people
you're seeing the complete
decentralization of how people get their
information you ha i was going through
like a lot of your episodes before
coming on and it's absolutely beautiful
450 000 people i mean for the last few
episodes watch your show yeah that is
beautiful and plus clips and and live
viewership isn't counted in that number
exactly and the thing is
what you're doing is exactly right you
are giving so many people the
information that they need and you don't
need to get 100 of the people you don't
even need 50
you need a solid 10 to 25 percent of
americans that are getting solid
information because those are the people
that are gonna go talk to their family
and friends and make sure that they know
the information there's like
10 to 25 percent of americans are just
helpless they're zombies then like
there's this 50 in the middle that are
actually persuadable and then there's
like us right like that are on the front
lines activist types i i think you're
actually doing the lord's work here and
i wouldn't lose hope i think there's a
lot to maybe maybe that's it maybe you
know what needs to happen is we're
growing we're building infrastructure
we're expanding we're doing new shows
we're getting uh a new headquarters and
then i guess what really happens is in
10 or 15 years these cable networks
won't exist anymore exactly you all know
it's crazy and this is no dick i'm a big
fan of it's always sunny but uh
i heard that it's always sunny in
philadelphia had a new season out
how many you guys are you guys have
heard of it
right it's now the longest running
live-action comedy series i guess so um
how many people how many viewers do you
think this show got
yeah on their seventh seventh season on
average how many people watched one
episode
would you that's the premiere yeah no no
no no not the premiere just like
throughout the season on average how
many people you think watched an episode
of it's always sunny in philadelphia i'm
going to pretend i'm not googling it
just tell me what you think 500 thousand
duckduckgo so it was it was about um i
think the premiere episode of season
seven was like 2 million wow and then
they would get like 1.3 to 1.5 million
per episode how many people do you think
watch
now
fifty thousand three hundred three two
two two hundred to three hundred
thousand per episode i'm not digging on
i'm a fan i think it's always sunny it's
funny i don't really watch it for the
most part i think what happens is
you know we've we've launched a couple
other shows we have the vlog we have
chicken city we have pop culture crisis
and i'm wondering if there's just
cultural swings in terms of what people
are interested in and sitcoms have just
you know there's too many options so
people are watching a bunch of different
shows
and
also
you know back when this show was at its
peak
we didn't have
this plethora of content and we didn't
have this plethora of streaming services
so what's happening is it's not so much
that people don't like the show it's
that over time people start using
technology and they start absorbing
information in different ways so the
reason i bring this up is that i think
it's entirely possible and likely that
within 10 or 15 years cnn just has
nothing and they're gone and then it
doesn't matter that people believe them
because there's nothing to believe
anymore they don't exist
however
10 years after that this show will be
outdated with limited viewership and
people will be in the metaverse or who
knows where it's all going to be shim
cast baby i'll ship yes
you plug your brain right into the
neural link and then shim speaks
directly into your mind
i think what's going to end up happening
too unfortunately and people are going
to have to be vigilant about this is
as you have mentioned it's very easy to
covertly fund people online so i think
there are going to be a lot of people
who want to promote the establishment
narrative who are going to be very well
funded by people from within the
establishment who traditionally would
have just given their money to cnn or
placed advertisements on their network
you see it
you know you see it on youtube the the
favorite channels they're they're trying
to prop up cnn you know so much to
perpetuate all these lies uh are you
guys familiar with defiant l's
yes yeah i think it was defined else who
had this it was um so what they do is
they show a tweet from someone and then
they show a follow-up which is like
failure yeah and it was like uh brian
stelter talking about you know we can't
just trust the cops on this justice
millet thing you know we got to hear it
out and the next one is like justice
millett sentenced to 100 days in jail
and it's just like yeah you know you
shouldn't be listening to people who are
i'll tell you this i can give him credit
for being a bit skeptical for sure
but it's like at some point you kind of
just say like we know
or we should air on the side of that was
bs yeah well the skepticism only ever
runs in one direction every single time
we hear an accusation of racial hatred
we're told if we don't buy into it hook
line and sinker it's because we actually
just hate black people and not that we
want more evidence before we jump to a
conclusion
yeah but when it runs in the other
direction when it's when it's a blm
activist or
jesse smallette hoaxing or doing
something illegal or corrupt well then
we need to stop and wait for the
evidence and make sure that we have all
the facts straight before we continue i
i can think of when of one time there
was a mass campaign with uh racist
vandalism uh it was carried out by a
bunch of young white men it was when
those white supremacists put up those
flyers everywhere saying it's okay to be
white that's right yeah yeah which it is
not it is not it's yeah apparently it is
not disavow disavow apparently that's
the message they're sending it's it was
brilliant trolling you know so you know
that was unfamiliar i think most people
know this they were it was a white sheet
of paper and it just said it's okay to
be white and people would put the
sticker on a pole and they'd be like
you're a white supremacist and they're
like that's crazy yeah this is an
interesting discussion i had with some
of my friends and i just want to ask you
guys do you identify as white me i don't
i i but i'm but everybody knows i'm like
yeah i'm more catholic than anything
yeah but actually everybody knows the
meme that i have second generation mixed
race family so we don't have that that's
like
i i guess they're people that are but
the idea is it's interesting the left
says see the reason you don't is because
you live in a world full of white people
so you're default yeah why would you
identify with what everyone else is but
in this is the problem with that
analysis firstly it's entirely
uncritical it's not actually looking at
specific ethnic backgrounds so irish
people and other ethnicities which were
generally more catholic as a matter of
fact such as the irish the italians the
polish were not considered white even
though we had white skin so i see
whiteness quote unquote is an identity
which is often been used to exclude
catholics well that's not something i
identify with that's partially what the
left critical race theorists argue that
whiteness is a political term and always
has been because there were white people
who who weren't white and they actually
argue now eastern europeans aren't white
like yeah luke
blonter blue eyes they say is a
personality
well here's the issue in the united
states we have a very unique racial
history as a result of slavery black
people unfortunately lost a lot of their
ethnic identity because they were
brought over here forcibly and were not
able to retain the information on what
part of africa they came from
specifically and i think that's become
rejected unto people who we call white
now even though they would have
considered themselves irish polish
italian dutch when they came over here
they're thrown into an analogous
category of white even though they're
more or less identifying or had
identified until much more recently with
their ethnic identity rather than their
racial identity
yeah this is exactly what but this is
this is one of the arguments from the
left that the reason why you know
there's no issue with black pride or
power is because they don't have an
ethnic identity they have a racial
identity because of what you just
described whereas for a white person you
could say you're proud of being irish or
scottish or ukrainian but not white yeah
but there's this kind of mountain valley
fallacy which they they engage in where
they will they will try to say things
like we're only against white privilege
in a system that places you on a
pedestal simply because of your skin
color we're not actually talking about
your skin color specifically but then
how do they identify you well buy your
skin color and they'll go after you and
say you're bad because you're white so
even though i don't identify as well you
want to talk about white privilege
justice millet yeah yeah if whiteness is
political then a a millionaire celebrity
who is propped up by the media and
defended when he commits a hoax and then
still has activists getting his back now
that's that's some kind of privilege and
at what point if whiteness is political
at what point would black people become
politically white it's like no it's a
serious that's a good question well i
mean they will call black conservative
activists white supremacists right i
mean literally white just means bad and
black means good that's how they use
these terms
yeah no and then you have the other
thing where like they're redefining all
these terms like the adl came out and
set define racism right as um
the support of systemic racism like they
use the same words to define it which is
always a really bad sign yes but
basically the only way you can be
anti-racist or against racism is to
support marxism yeah like hundred
percent
the adl
changed the definition of racism to be
about something like racial dominance or
something like that
and then had to change it again
like a week later and apologize because
something happened in like a jewish
community and they were like oh maybe we
should have thought about what we were
what we were claiming
because people started saying you
couldn't be racist against jewish people
or something like that and then often
the adl was like we better
refer ourselves to whoopi goldberg
oh yeah yeah she she she she's she knows
all um well apparently they used to
arrest people like tucker carlson and
tulsi gabbard for you know pushing
propaganda which is not true you know
that whole whoopi goldberg scandal got
just memory hold like it's like it never
even happened oh right that that would
that's what it was right the adl that's
what happened for anyone she came out
that was amazing she said that wasn't
racist that was just white people you
know with white people and then the
adult realized like hmm
this this uh this uh whiteness
definition of racism is really
backfiring on you know like the jewish
community
maybe they shouldn't have tried playing
the vote game and then they realized
they had to change it back by the way i
i can't i saw a hysterical tweet someone
called them the adl the anti-definition
league
that was fantastic thought that was
fantastic very clever yeah very clever
but i'll also say too it's always funny
when people will define racism as
systemic racism specifically because a i
mean you lose the ability to analyze
racism at the level of individual
behavior rather than just looking at it
systemically but on top of that you
mentioned using definitions
when or using the actual word you're
defining within the definition this is
the first thing you are taught in any
etymology class
if you want to define a word you cannot
use that word definition exactly so i
don't know if uh
i don't know if i mentioned this in the
show about the uh the black card revoked
we talked about that right maybe the
black card revoked
we went to uh uh i think we were in
altoona pennsylvania was it altoona
maybe not yeah i think it was i don't
know anyway we're at an airbnb
and they had a bunch of board games one
of the they had a pack of cards and it
was called black card revoked yeah we
talked about this with gothics oh yeah
yeah and uh oh that's right that's right
it was a card game that was supposed to
be
you know if you if it was it was for
black people to play and it was about
black culture and it asked questions
like what movie does every black person
have in their collection and i thought
it was racist and i'm like man i but hey
far be it for me it was it was made and
marketed by you know black people for
black people so
there you go i guess i don't know if
it's racist or not if these things are
held by you know to be true by them but
one of the questions was
if quote unquote they give reparations
what should they give and i was like why
is they in quotes
they in is a reference to jewish people
right because when you're referring to
authorities of of any power you just say
they or them
when it's put in quotes it's a specific
reference to jewish people and so i saw
that and i was like that's kind of weird
and and look
i don't know i think maybe the people
who made this game are anti-semites it's
possible because they have ties to you
know high-profile politicians you know
we're we're looking at that story maybe
there's something there i don't know but
we know that there's a lot of prominent
black lives matter activists that are
deeply anti-semitic yeah we saw this at
the women's march these individuals were
forced to resign because they were
pushing insane conspiracy theories about
the jewish people yeah well look if you
tell people that any time a group of
people is successful it's because
they're stealing something from you
they're going to look at every
successful group of people and say
they're stealing something from us i
don't know why anyone thought that that
would start and end with white people
yeah
yeah that's why i can't stand the uh
just like the general anti-semitic like
so
anti-semitism in general is annoying to
me because it's the same it's the same
crt argument a privileged group of
people
dominate i'm like get out of here dude
like any look i know i there are ceos of
big companies and in media who are not
of a particular ethnic background it's
it can be anybody who works hard and
succeeds it's weird that people are like
i notice there's a whole lot of one
group of people in this industry that
proves it and i'm like dude that's a
privilege argument that's that's that's
a that's that's ridiculous argument i'm
not playing that game well and if you
know like i have friends who are
orthodox shoes and
the reason that they're
that they have influence and they that
they are successful is because they have
such a strong community like they
they're community it's family it's their
it's their friends like they are so
tight-knit like they help pay for each
other's kids like tuition at school they
they
i wish that like catholics had a
community similar to that yeah because
it's so strong and it's it's it's admire
admirable um really and for me i was
getting there honestly though i'm seeing
it a lot of places with with catholics
the annoying thing to me about the
anti-semitism be it from blm or from
like white supremacist groups or
whatever it's like right now in new york
we've had this ongoing problem where
hasidic jews are being chased down and
brutally beaten and i'm just like where
where is the great power structure to
intervene and tell the police to
actually deal with this hate that's
happening on the streets and and
but they don't why because the people
who run new york also are deeply
anti-semitic right so i mean it's like
for you know for the it's not bill de
blasio anymore but that dude is a far
leftist who probably held all of these
same insane beliefs and so this idea
that one group has privilege over the
others yeah sometimes some groups do but
i think the real issue is merit
merit
drive and a little bit of luck sprinkled
on top chance favors they're prepared
but for the most part if you if you are
smart and you work really hard you'll
become successful but ultimately we've
talked about this before when it comes
to you know uh uh you know why you see a
high propensity of successful jewish
individuals could it be family we know
that family is a key indicator of
success regardless of your religious
background
as you are saying with the catholics and
well no but family is is everything
right like
lydia and i were talking about this
before the show family is why you get a
job family is why you go to work family
is why you love your country and why you
go to war and you're willing to die in
it so that your kids and your grandkids
can have a good life like family drives
everything and like it's like the social
science on this is so boring because
it's so predictable right like kids
raised in a loving household with
parents that take them to church on
sunday are always the best performing
group they're they commit less crime
they don't commit suicide they don't get
addicted to drugs it's all very boring
and it's all basic and
and you know
the jewish community is like really
figure that out are you familiar with
the uh blue zones
no it's where
the uh there's like seven areas of the
planet where people haven't have a life
expectancy that exceeds 100 or why
there's like the highest propensity
towards having people live over 100
and so some researchers went to these
areas
to figure out what do they have in
common
that may contribute to people living to
be over a hundred
and there's there's some interesting
things like they eat only until they're
about 85 percent full they don't overeat
but one of the one of the most
interesting things is they all they all
have a job
so they talk to this one he's a japanese
guy and he's like 102 and he's chopping
wood and they're like why are you doing
this shouldn't you be relaxing and be
retired and he's like well if i don't do
it who will
someone's got to get the wood and it was
for his communities first family
community and family was another big
part of it they're very close-knit and
tight-knit family uh families and
communities and the reason he had to
chop the wood was because he needed to
make sure everybody had this available
and if he didn't no one else would yep i
was also reading that
the highest uh um like the biggest spike
in when deaths occur is right after
retirement yeah so i think i think
people need to understand how important
purpose is
in in a human's life without purpose
people become dejected depressed and
violent like we see with so many young
people these days and with purpose we
see a lot of people living to be over
100 years old yep that's right and
actually there's a lot of uh studies
that have come out over the last few
decades that show the benefits of
not just like having children like for
your mental health like down the road
but um like
super old people when they're around
their grandkids a lot their cognitive
ability like they don't they they can
like reverse parts of dementia and and
erosion in the brain it's it's really
cool stuff and it's it's i think you're
right it's about duty it's about
responsibility it's about purpose
because when you lose that like so many
people when they retire what my
great-grandmother lived to be 95 and she
didn't really start to
fall apart until she got out of her
daily routine
she used to go to the the library
she went to two goodwill stores the
thrift store and and uh and the goodwill
she went to all the grocery stores
coupons as soon as she stopped doing
that she just kind of fell apart think
about it from an evolutionary
perspective
you've got a finite amount of energy in
a certain area and resources for a life
form be it human or otherwise
and so
what happens if
there is a group of people or a group of
animals and several of them stop
producing for the rest of their herd
it's a strain on the herd and so then
what happens is the old you know it it
stands to reason that
life evolves
duty and purpose
because those who have a sense of duty
and purpose to each other are more
likely to survive more likely to have
kids and thus those traits are carried
on into the future with us thus family
and community are extremely important
the other interesting thing too is i
think purpose
you have to have a reason to to do
things to be alive otherwise
we're we're we're facing uh the rat
utopia experiment in my opinion are you
familiar we've mentioned it several
times and recently this is where they
put a bunch of rats in a you know
unlimited food in limited water but
finite space what happens when you don't
have when you don't have to fight for
food what happens when you don't have to
do any work you're lazy it's it's not
just that they they found what
they found what they called behavioral
sync behavior started to break down
cannibalism emerged some rats would just
groom themselves incessantly and never
do anything they would engage in strange
behaviors and if they took one of the
rats out of the utopia and put it with a
regular population its ideas would
persist and spread
so without purpose and without struggle
humans become
likely in my opinion will become broken
you know and unhealthy yeah things fall
apart and i would say i mean even beyond
the sort of more materialistic darwinian
analysis we can just say that human
beings have deep spiritual needs there's
something about us that's very
mysterious and difficult to understand
and we're not contributing to something
that we understand is greater than
ourselves we do start to fall apart
yeah absolutely you you need that drive
we've looked into this actually a lot on
the economic side of things and the
funny thing is is like you would think
that you know having kids and getting
married would like you know put you
further back in terms of how much money
you're making it's actually not true and
there's this weird thing um a lot of
experts think that
when you have children it's actually a
bigger motivator to get a better job
start you know invest more in your
business so you can provide better but
it's it's
overall like when you sh when you have
to struggle you have to cut the fat
right you have to become more efficient
um and it just keeps you on your toes
like and
family i think helps drive that
community helps drive that for a lot of
people they have no purpose and i think
yeah if you look at the millennial
generation
i wonder what it could be well there's
two things no religion no kids
yeah so then what do they live for for
people who a long time ago well i'm not
saying this to say that people
should be religious but certainly
without religion we can see people
become listless
we used to have you know people had
faith they had community
religion served several purposes you
would go to church and that meant you
were with your community you were
communicating with each other you were
sort of synchronizing a lot of ways it
was a chance for the people who lived
next to each other to talk about what
was affecting them so that was important
we don't have that anymore people don't
even talk to their neighbors anymore
it's really weird it is when i was
growing up like
i was always with my neighbors like we
they weren't then they all went to
different churches right i mean some of
my friends went to the same church as me
but like we had a neighborhood gang
we would literally ride our bikes around
we'd build forts like and you would we
knew all the other neighbors even if
they didn't have kids and they would
talk to us and you know hang out yeah
block parties
and that doesn't happen anymore
especially in new york man you go to new
york and you live on top of somebody you
never met them that's the weirdest thing
to me yeah every apartment i've ever had
you know i'm in new york city i was
living off of um
myrtle and nostrand and there's uh there
are people my age behind me below me and
above me and it's like why don't i know
who they are no i could probably play
xbox together and order pizza if i just
talk to them talk to the guy
never did yeah just never happens yeah
in a very strange way the internet has
actually alienated us from our own
actual location there's been something
wonderful about the fact that it's given
access or given us access to people who
are nowhere near us but you stop forming
social connections with the people who
are right next to you
yeah
let's talk about some more media lies
and family and all that stuff we got the
story from politico
americans split over florida's
controversial bills on gender identity
and race so controversial let me just
slow down here and correct the article
before we get into it they're of course
referring to the parental rights and
education bill which the democrats call
don't say gay which is a lie it's weird
it is uh controversial fine i guess but
it is not a bill on gender identity and
race that seems strange to me the bulk
of the bill in florida as we often
clarify is parents have a right to know
what's happening yep that and no sex sad
for preschoolers to third grade five six
seven eight years old that's it teachers
are still allowed to talk to kids and
say the word gay to their faces a
teacher can still go up to a child and
say you should be gay that is not being
banned in any way
makes you wonder what republicans are
actually doing bill doesn't even nearly
go far enough
so here we go i love this politico says
the poll asked respondents about
florida's parental rights and education
dubbed the don't say gay bill by
opponents now here's the funny thing in
their actual poll the question refers to
it as don't say gay
and i'm like that is not proper polling
dishonest but you're still seeing the
majority
say they agree with it i really don't
like how they're framing it as americans
being sharply divided on this issue i
mean there's a 16 point gap there and
you've got 30 this is an issue where 33
of democrats
support what desantis did
yeah that's not sharply divided i'm
sorry like when you're over 50 and your
opponents are at 35 imagine if donald
trump had beaten joe biden by you know
51 to 35
that's a landslide right like so it's
just the whole thing is skewed the
questions are skewed um but
they had to at least admit it that they
were that they're not one of the crazy
things is that uh
69 of americans support the banning of
sputnik and rt it appears
i mean that's kind of crazy to me
you should just
watch that stuff knowing it's probably
bunk but see what they're telling people
for sure but i'm gonna try i'm gonna see
if i can find the uh the exact exact
question here because it's funny the
political poll question is not just a
here we go instead of saying
uh do you support
the parental rights and education bill
out of florida they say this
as you may know the florida legislature
has passed a bill labeled by opponents
as the don't say gay bill limiting the
teaching of sexual orientation and
gender identity to florida school
students some say that limiting these
discussions will protect children from
inappropriate classroom topics while
others say it will block important
conversations about lgbtq issues to what
extent do you support or oppose the
following items in the bill banning the
teaching of sexual orientation and
gender and identity from kindergarten
through third grade
strong support is 37 percent somewhat
support is 13 and then somewhat opposes
11 strongly opposed 23. we're to clearly
see the majority there is in favor of uh
in in support of it they then go on to
ask the basic basically the same
question and then say limiting lessons
on orientation and identity after third
grade to age appropriate discussions and
you still have the majority 32 percent
in support of 20 somewhat supporting so
you still have the majority there being
like yeah it should be age appropriate
my question is what would the percentage
have been if they didn't frame this
in favor of lies from the democrats on
the left they tell you
what the opponents of the bill call it
but not the actual name right in the
question how much bias can you get with
it and they push the lie from the
democrats instead of telling you what
the bill actually does they say
opponents say
it will block important conversations
about lgbtq issues that's irrelevant
what if they said this let me read you
the question reframed as you may know
the florida legislature has passed a
bill labeled by opponents as the don't
say straight bill limiting the teaching
of orientation and identity to florida
school students some say that limiting
these discussions will protect children
from inappropriate classroom topics
while others say it will block important
conversations about traditional marriage
issues to what extent do you support or
oppose the following items in the bill
there's no difference in the bill
i could literally call it don't say
straight and say republicans have just
banned teaching children about
traditional marriage that's true
literally true but see politico comes
out and they polled people now here's
here's why i bring this up
even though they falsely framed the
story based on lies
the majority still agree with it exactly
it's weird there's like a super majority
of americans and i know this is this is
pretty radical like that the vast
majority of americans
they don't want to sexualize kids like
they want to let them be kids you know
like why do we have to make everything
sexual not every someone tweeted at me
today they said not everything has to be
gay and i think that that's right like
yeah great you do you live your life
fine
but not everything has to be about you i
remember back um
there was a there was a cartoon
made by this uh uh this guy he was on
reddit i can't remember his name he
deleted it it was about atheism on
reddit read it when it first started one
of the default subreddits getting a ton
of attention was r
atheism that meant if you were a random
regular person who went to reddit you
would see posts from people about being
atheist
so he made this cartoon
where he basically mocked the idea
because
reddit propped up a community that was
just ragging on people for what they
believed and it's like why
you know why is that a thing why is that
the default position why
you know
i kind of forgot where i was going with
that but ultimately what ends up
happening is
the dude deleted the cartoon and you
can't find it anywhere anymore i mean
maybe it's been archived somewhere but
it was actually i thought it was a great
point because
the cartoon ends by saying like why is
this a default subreddit to just
you know be on everyone's speed
yeah like why just just you know be mean
to people all the time why just prop
that up
i lost my train of thought with with my
point so you guys just start talking
well the the big thing here is like
this stuff really is happening across
the country like we did this uh video uh
last week uh showing like say basically
saying thank you to governor desantis
for protecting our kids from women like
this in our kids public schools and it's
this woman who started this sexy summer
camp and she's talking about um
she's talking about how she's like i
encourage every kid kids of all ages all
ages to you know basically abuse
themselves and she starts talking about
how her nephews who started abusing
themselves when they were toddlers like
what's going into this and it's like
guys this is happening like there's a
co-work a coordinated effort to
sexualize your kids and like break them
and so thank god you know i remember my
point now
basically i brought that up because what
the community was doing was it making it
was making a whole bunch of people who
didn't know a whole lot about religion
just blindly be
part of this hate mob against
christianity but nothing else
and so when when you look at what's
what's happening after the don't say gay
or whatever there's like a tick-tock
video where a guy is like wearing a
shirt with pride flags on it and it's
like
why why do that
what do you think is happening they
don't look at the news they don't read
the bill they have no idea this is so
it's not just about the atheism
community on reddit or anything like
that it's about the fact that there is
some truth to out of sight well out of
sight out of mind is literally true if
you can control what people see from the
bulk of their social media you are
controlling what they will complain
about so what do we get on twitter
people are talking about covid and then
one day like a switch was flicked it's
ukraine yup because they want to make
sure the only thing you see is this
these stories of this information this
is why the democrats called it don't say
gay they want to make the argument yeah
and then even ben shapiro walks into
that trip ben shapiro tweeted to ted lou
this bill stops you from indoctrinating
kids with your weird gender ideology or
whatever something that affects and i'm
like no it doesn't it literally does not
do that the democrats made up a lie they
claimed here's the framing of the bill
conservatives walked into it and said
well actually that framing of the bill
is a good thing and it's like both of
you are talking about something totally
irrelevant to what's going on
but this is this is the game
media will often frame things i'll i'll
put it this way as well i'll say this
politico doing a poll where they give
you a paragraph breaking down an issue
is a total violation of polling ethics
in my opinion they should say this
how do you feel about the parental
rights and education bill out of florida
strongly support somewhat support
somewhat oppose some would oppose don't
know or no opinion and guess what would
happen don't know would be 80 exactly
and hey that would be funny wouldn't it
yep instead the funny thing is they
still try and frame it in favor of the
left's argument and the majority of
people actually still support your bill
yep it's really it's got to be
depressing for them
because they have no i mean think about
all the levers of cultural influence
that the left has here right like
they've got the mainstream media they've
got hollywood they've got the music
industry corporate america big tech like
everything like they control so many
sources of information and they still
can't win on something like this
well
i think maybe their power is faltering
you know
less and less people are interested in
the lies the lies have become more and
more obvious i think of it like they say
that wealth lasts three generations
someone works really really hard and
builds a big business becomes a
billionaire right their son and or
daughter inherits it and then takes the
company over and maintains it they have
kids
no so what happens is
you know the the child of the
entrepreneur was still taught the values
of hard work but not you know was was
not someone who founded a company and
could maintain that then they have kids
who are taught to a certain degree the
value of hard work but certainly not how
to start a company or even to maintain
it so by the third generation you see
wealth start to fizzle out well i think
of it uh similarly in terms to how the
democrats have institutional control and
how the media is playing
it seems like you know a couple two
generations ago media was strongly
controlled by savvy marketers who were
like keen and manipulating
then their kids inherit it and they're
like keep the system up keep it rolling
you know cnn or whatever
now we're on the third third generation
who are just like i have no idea what's
going on and so they tried doing the
most outrageous and garbage propaganda
that doesn't work and we're waking up to
it yeah well it's interesting because
one theme that has repeatedly come up as
we've discussed the quote unquote don't
say gay bill is that if you're going to
refer to it as an anti-grooming bill it
does which would be great it doesn't go
nearly far enough and the left hears
that young children below a certain age
are not going to be discussing sexuality
in the classroom when it would be wildly
inappropriate and they go oh my goodness
but what about gay people how are we
going to protect them instead of saying
look this is a bill that is specifically
set up to protect children from
inappropriate discussions and also to
ensure that parents are notified by
certain things that the school district
might otherwise try to keep from them
even though they have a right to know as
parents and all the left can think about
is what about protecting the poor sweet
gays that's literally it and and and
that's why i think it's better to call
it the don't say straight bill and
i am outraged
these republicans are banning
discussions on traditional marriage
i i i agree with the democrats we should
come together and say we should be
allowed to teach kids about traditional
marriage we should that should actually
be the standard right like i mean this
is this is the truth this is what you
should be shooting for um i still have
no problem with being like we're not
going to talk to preschoolers or third
graders about you know about sexuality
well yeah this is the bizarre thing
right imagine thinking you're going to
get public opinion on your side
trying to fight a bill that says you
can't talk to children
below a certain age about sexuality with
but then
gay people won't be able to tell
children about their sexuality when
they're in preschool who like what world
do they live in that they think the
average person is going to hear that and
go oh no oh my goodness sheamus
according to this poll at least we have
around 34 of people who don't like that
so you've got a third it's true if we
were to extrapolate the data
who are hearing this from politico
probably for the first time and saying
four-year-olds should be taught these
things
you know i thank goodness that i don't
know anyone who would be in support of
that virtually i mean maybe i do know
some people who are lefty so i made
friends with when i was younger who if
you yeah but about this and reconnected
might say that supported it but they're
zombies yeah exactly those are
conversations with that's disgusting i
have a lot of friends from back during
occupy i have a lot of you know that i
talk to and they
don't know what's in the bill that's
what i'm saying yeah this is dangerous
you know how do you how do you defeat uh
you we have a police we have political
zombification in this country we have a
horde tens of millions of political
zombies and they are tearing away at our
system no no that's that's right but
here's where here's where donald trump
was a huge benefit to the movement is
that he showed us basically how to fight
back and that you could actually call
out the bs and the lies and end up
winning these political battles and now
you're seeing that being transferred to
desantis and desantis is calling it out
that press conference he had was really
beautiful and i know you know another
example of this and he's not the
greatest example but it is greg abbott
with what he did with that executive
order now agree or disagree on on what
he should have done with that executive
order uh the one declaring gender
modifications for minors to be child
abuse right so
there are some disagreements on that but
guess what he trolled the entire
national news media into saying
and letting americans know that this is
happening yeah gender modifications for
children are happening and by the way
republicans think it's child abuse
something that like 80 percent of
americans actually agree on we polled on
this um and even like 60 percent of
democrats want to ban this stuff
absolutely yeah i mean
i i think the issue with the debt with
with your average democrat who votes
democrats they don't know anything about
what's going on exactly yeah so how you
you know we've got this battle
i think one of the core elements of the
culture war is people who are discerning
who watch the news and seek out true
information and try and fact check and
you have people who don't
the people who don't are being you know
hypnotized i'm just imagining there's
brian stelter and he's got his you know
watch going left and right don't watch
fox news only we can give you the true
good information and i think it was jake
tapper who said you can't read wikileaks
emails only only we can do that was that
tabernacle no cuomo cuomo was that was
cuomo i'm pretty
either one of them whatever cuomo's gone
but you have regular people who uh
until you sit down and talk with them
you know like i've told before i have
friends who say they'll talk to their
parents like hey watch tim's show and
hear what he has to say and they're like
ah i don't want to watch that conspiracy
stuff and they're like he's reading
cnn.com
like he's reading politico polls they're
just giving their thoughts on this and
like a critical assessment and then i
actually end up sitting down with my
friend and they ask questions they're
like nah trump did this and i'm like oh
actually xyz and then they're like well
i didn't hear that i'll pull it up and
show them like one of my favorite
stories when i was talking about china
stealing the dna from people that's
terrifying it was it was an npr story
that china was getting access to
people's dna through covet testing and
there are people who didn't believe me
and they were like that's conspiracy
mumbo jumbo and i'm like npr right here
like i i if you don't believe it and i
got no problem i don't trust npr half
the time either
but what is it do you trust npr or not
well but that's the kind of thing that
npr would be incentivized against
reporting on which makes me more likely
to trust them about it because their
general interest is in promoting
information that makes all of the kova
testing and vaccines etc sound better
rather than worse so if they're willing
to say that it's probably because they
have something yeah i also think that
common sense should take a play right
like there's there's this over
expertization
thing too as well like we have to like
read these things and it doesn't matter
if it's fox news npr cnn msnbc
you if you if you have a little bit of
common sense you can sniff out bs right
like it does i don't care what degree
you have or you know if you have a phd
or whatever but we are battling against
the bill burs and the ethan kleins you
know bill burr who went on joe rogan and
said
look joe i just turn on the tv
every two weeks
and do what they tell me to do and it's
just like
if they told you to walk off a cliff
would you do it like you have you have a
limit you have a red line right you get
ethan klein who's like you even got to
think about it man you just go to the
cdc and you just tell you what to do and
it's just like
yo throughout history governments have
oppressed people how could you be a
supporter of resistance if you're
telling people to just blindly walk in
lockstep with the government's mandates
that's what we're battling against
there's like a complacency and a
laziness like people don't want to deal
with um
really bad things right like we we end
up like there's like a psychosis around
that like when things are really bad we
don't want to pay attention we just it's
a human thing and that's why it always
has there's a cycle to it well i i'm
curious what would the nra for families
have to say about this and try to do
about these problems
about all so
basically we where we're coming at it is
like start with the basics right like we
we wanted to get politicians comfortable
talking about the transgender issue like
the left wants to put gender identity to
civil rights law
that has major consequences men and
women sports men and women's private
spaces men and women's prisons like
men women's uh you know uh homeless
shelters like there's a lot of really
bad things here and so we started with
the sports because that was what
politicians wanted to talk about but
in reality
americans are broken sexually like we
have disconnected sex from family we've
disconnected it from children it's now
just totally hedonistic and you're a
weirdo if you have six kids right like
have you seen the meme where it's like
it's like you know i think it's like
nine kids lined up and then the mom's
pregnant and then there's like a bunch
of leftists saying like this is
disgusting and stuff like
i mean but that just
shows their misanthropic hand they hate
human life ultimately they really do
they'll never acknowledge it what they
love is pleasure and engaging in
pleasure and they see other human beings
existence is very inconvenient to them
because that requires that they set
themselves aside and make choices that
are for the benefit of others what's the
article it's like in order for there to
be a feminist utopia the family must be
destroyed or something like that yeah no
that was part of the marxist movement
it's true yep yeah well because you need
to you know people uh this is
interesting back during occupy wall
street
there were uh two different govern
governance governments i don't know what
you'd want to call it there was the
general assembly which was everyone
gathered around and then the
facilitators effectively controlled what
could be said by who and when and how
money was spent but then you had a group
of people who tried creating what's
called the general union
and these guys explained it to me that
the way the union would work is that
every tent at occupy was a family that
knew each other's interests desires and
needs
and so a representative from each family
would discuss with the larger group
instead of a group of random people all
adhering to perhaps you know the
authority who facilitate the meetings i
thought it was interesting that their
approach from it was we're a family
we have needs amongst each other we'll
convey those needs to other families and
then ultimately see how that greatly you
know but that was crushed the general
unit was basically wiped out of the park
they were ostracized they were smeared
and lied about it's like they reinvented
the wheel yeah right like how society
works like it is organized by families i
think we've gone
the reality is and sheamus you were
talking about this earlier like we went
decades without a like robust lobbying
special interest group in dc
representing families like who makes
politicians pay a price when they were
voting to trans our kids or voting to
allow pornography unrestricted you know
no age verification
they just they they say these things
don't happen and right the problem is
once and it's good that they do
but so yeah in the long run i think you
know we're starting to see that the
narratives start cracking people start
realizing what's going on with their
kids one of the one of the things i
think is really important not west
virginia it's happening people think
they can move to west virginia which is
the second most trump supporting state
in the country after i think it was
wyoming they think they're going to go
there and find a red school that's going
to be like
middle of the road look we're not here
to teach your kids to be religious we're
just going to you know teach your kids
let them be kids play baseball and
they'll learn math and then it turns out
that these woke activists are still
running for school board in red areas on
purpose they have a mission they have a
cause they found their purpose
so you you get these kids
who are going to grade school in west
virginia and they're surrounded by all
of the cult locism
they have all of these books like
whiteness contracts and stuff like that
neighbor mex candy and then when you
point it out they call you a liar and
say you're making up and the media
protects them yep so human beings have a
natural desire to procreate and it's
very strange how over the past 50 60
years or so that has been branded is
sort of a strange uniquely religious
impulse
at bottom it's in all of us and people
who are not procreating or reproducing
sexually try to find other ways to
spread what they are to other people and
so these woke activists they're
essentially the byproduct of a society
that has stopped seeing sex as something
which is beautiful and unitive and
procreative and can literally
create a human soul which will outlast
the stars and the mountains and
everything you've seen in this world
and into something that's just there for
me to get a little bit of pleasure out
of and so what happens is people become
fundamentally restructured towards
selfishness in pursuing hedonistic
pleasure and because they're not
procreating in the traditional way they
have to make your children like them
because that urge doesn't disappear
maybe i think worse they're animals well
i think i think robot's a better word
than zombie for for a lot of people
because
there's something special with um with
existence and life in general and
especially with human life there's
something special there's unique the
human experience the feelings that we
have but if you reduce everything to
their mechanical functions which is
often what you'll see from you know the
modern left then there is no unique
human experience it's just all the
function it's all random it's all chaos
when in reality i i'll put it this way
there's there's a there's there's a view
uh among you know many atheists and and
more of the left that you know emotions
are just you know response to stimuli
for for for to help you know propagate
the species and all that humans have
these reactions and all that really is
you know that life is random there's
nothing else out there
i find that fascinating because i prefer
the doctor manhattan view of it have you
read or watched watchmen no oh no no
tell me about it dr manhattan
uh uh is he's this he's this doctor he's
dr osterman and he's involved in an
accident which strips him of his
intrinsic field he then uh one day this
body just reforms in the lab where he
was working and he has access to
manipulate time and space and he
perceives you know throughout you know
multiple dimensions or whatever and uh
so he's he's effectively a superman he's
almost the humans referred him as a
god-like because he has telekinesis and
he can teleport but he says he is not
god he is not omniscient he just can see
his future in past so anyway he ends up
getting sick of humanity he leaves and
goes to mars
but uh this young woman who he had been
dating you know before
is trying to beg him to come back and he
says
you know i have seen things you know or
he he says a bunch of things you know
like that effectively are
life doesn't even matter he says look at
mars for you know tens of thousands of
years it has existed without life and
could you say it was not better off what
what would huma you know what good would
mars gain by having humans on it
and so
he he can see the future you know in a
certain sense he tells the the young
woman who's with him that you know
she'll leave crying
and he says you keep telling me that i
refuse to see you know your your you
know your way but you refuse to see the
world my way because he wants her to
perceive time and everything the way he
does so he she can understand the sort
of futility so in the in in the story he
then you know puts his hand on her head
she can then see past and future but he
can also see her pass in future and what
he sees is that her mother
was
attacked by this other guy who tried to
rape her
and uh she got beaten up by him but
someone came and stopped it she then
later went and met with this guy and had
sex with him and then got pregnant with
this woman and gave birth to her and
that kind of shocks dr manhattan who is
this very you know computeristic like
methodical
lacking emotion and then he says he was
wrong and he realized that
you know he he he thought he had never
seen a miracle before but then he
realized that
in her
all of these random moments and all of
this energy and all of these things that
should not have come together come
together in such astronomical odds that
you could only describe humans as that
miracle so what he was basically saying
is like your mother and he's like out of
all the billions of years out of all of
the different life forms that came and
died all it comes down to your mother
who loved a man she had every reason to
hate and from it is just you and all of
those things forming this one moment
could be described as a miracle and so
that's the human experience i love that
the way of thinking about it that we are
these unique entities that took billions
of years to finally you know come to or
however long you think that everything
that was around us ultimately leads to
this point
and it seems like the odds are are
astronomically it's beyond comprehension
and that's something magnificent and
unique and special so the people who
look at this and say it's random it's
it's whatever i'll be like yo winning
the lottery is random but boy is it
special when you do now your life and
your uniqueness is
100 billion times winning the lottery
now that's something truly special and
unique that's a really awesome way to
think about it a unique human being
created by you is
yeah more
more like astronomically uh
at odds than winning the lottery exactly
and i want to mention this because i'd
be remiss not to correct myself maybe by
being pedantic here but when i mentioned
parents creating life or souls i mean
you are collaborating with god in that
creative process it's it's really
interesting so um i've been around the
block on this issue and like because i
get asked a lot about like like gay
adoption right like and you know i think
there's a lot like i'm i'm not weirded
out by gays i'm not freaked out by them
but what i what i think is is like
i i had this experience with uh someone
that my family knows where
they got married as a lesbian couple and
they end up uh getting uh pregnant they
get a sperm donor the one has it and
when the baby's born
the other
spouse is like well that that's not my
baby yeah that that doesn't look like me
it wasn't my egg i didn't i didn't birth
it and so they did another thing where
like
they had an egg from the other spouse
that didn't have the baby and planted
into the other mother and then they
um
they had it but they they would fight
over which kid was cuter
right and stuff like that and they you
know and it's like
i can't do that with my wife i mean
we'll do it like tongue-in-cheek right
like oh he's such a little [ __ ] like
you know
uh he's looks like his father but like
i can't my kids but my wife and i's kids
they're actually 50 of both of us yeah
and they're either like they might look
like her or look like me
but they're still made by us and so
there's like this intrinsic unity with
the family and when you have kids and
you're married and you know making new
human life i was reading something and
it said um
it was like a meme on reddit or whatever
but they were like why do you want to
have kids and the person said because if
i don't i would be the first life form
through billions of years of procreation
not to have a child correct and i was
like that's kind of scary if you think
about it like
every single ancestor that you have had
a child
every single one of them had a child
yeah and if you don't that's the end of
that chain of that history of that
whatever you want to call it something
something massive and profound and
bigger than you ends if you do not have
a child yep yeah well and i think there
are some people who are not called to
have children that's fine it's okay for
that lineage to end with you but if you
are called to have children that that is
a very beautiful thing that is a very
beautiful thing to do and um as i'm sort
of mentioning earlier you know you're
collaborating with god in this creative
process and of course he creates the
soul but to be a parent and to have a
child that you are bringing into the
world through his his graces and the
ability he's given you to do so is such
a beautiful and profound thing and yet
as a culture we don't just have an
indifference towards it we're actually
disgusted by it and you know too you
know i was just mentioning how it's like
you know having a child is like
infinitely like at more at odds than
winning the lottery like the uniqueness
and the rarity of that is something
truly special i mean and if you're
really concerned about money and you'd
rather buy the lotto ticket just think
about this have the kid
bring him to hollywood you know and then
boom 18 not even maybe not even 18 years
maybe you get a child star then you're
rich
you know just put them to work in la and
that was what they do in hollywood keep
your kid as far away as possible from
those people
yeah something something tells me i can
tell you where the hollywood people will
stand on this bill yeah they're going to
be like tim's right bring your kids yeah
like no no i was kidding i made any
mistakes do not ever bring your child
here no yeah
yeah man well this is the the the world
we're in now is that
you we we have two distinct
visions of reality and it's it's very
strange and this is why i often talk
about transhumanism i don't know if you
rewrite a lot into it but clearly
those of us who are not
talking about living in a digital world
or having a an internal identity or
anything like that outside of you know
ourselves
we live in base reality i suppose
and then this other faction of people
they live in a
digital or or you know
just a different version of reality i
wonder if the internet is helping uh
create
this sense of separate identity from
your body because people now have a way
to go on online especially now with vr
and create avatars create you know
facsimiles or representations of
themselves and so
whereas for the most of human
civilization
you were your body
i mean now we have people who exist in a
different space where they engage in
commerce and communications but they
create a different version of themselves
for these spaces even different voices
if they end up speaking voice changers
or otherwise cartoon versions of
themselves what happens then when those
people enter the metaverse they will
create whatever
version of themselves they want but for
those of us that just maintain base
reality live here and carry on we're
gonna have families we're gonna have
kids and we're just gonna be like i'm
just some dude here in blue jeans i mean
we already see it very much so that
people don't want to live in base
reality and what they're trying to do is
take their own mental reality their
subjective experience of what the world
is and what their place should be in it
rather than what their place actually is
what they think it should be and then
they're trying to transform their bodies
in accordance with that that's the
entirety of the transgender movement
truth be told i would love virtual
virtual reality skyrim is so much fun
you know when the new elder scrolls come
out i'm going to put that vr on and i'm
going to be firing the bow and arrow at
some dragons but the interesting thing
to me is that you know when i play these
games it's just like first person it's
your hands and they're moving around i'm
still me i still view myself as me
there's there's you know for me i don't
go into these video games and think i
want to be someone else i just think i
want to throw a fireball at a dragon but
there are some people who go into these
spaces specifically to escape and to be
something else
they go in chat rooms and lie about who
they are they go into video games and
create avatars specifically to be a
different person
i wonder if one of the issues we just
have is at the root people aren't taught
to love themselves yep or or really how
to love anything yeah right like and
that's been the there's been this huge
rise in uh vr porn i did this debate
series with um
brandy love uh you know she's an active
porn star and she's like actually pretty
honest she's a good i think she
ultimately for porn star she's pretty
great um and and a moral person i think
but the thing is is like
she even she was freaked out by vr porn
because she was like i i just think it's
a little bit too weird i think that you
know with when it comes to sex it's
really important to have another person
and to share that with someone else and
virtual reality really is like people
trying to escape reality yeah and it's
terrible i think that's where we're
going for sure and that's what happened
and look yeah there was a one of the
quotes i love to say on the show you
know every so often is
google it you know tell me who said this
because i was reading a long time ago
they said that if humans ever meet
aliens we will shake hands not because
we overcame nuclear weapons but because
we overcame the xbox
and the point of the the article was
that humans
are continually chasing after
self
um satisfying actions like you know
what do we do we we create a massive
industry for porn
we we create food sugars and fats and
desserts these are the things that just
trigger other reward centers in our
brain and all that stuff and so
where will people end up
what the i think at this point the
article's probably outdated but i would
i would say at this point we're seeing
with the metaverse and everything
most people are going to they will beg
for neuralink they will just be like i
don't care who's in charge i don't care
if you can erase my brain i want to be a
magic elf fighting a dragon more than
anything just get me out of this and
they'll take it
and they'll be dead
that's the that's three there's this
weird belief in it and transgenderism is
the precursor to transhumanism it's it's
i i disagree on that one
well i think i think you know the the
issue is we're seeing a whole bunch of
uh um identity
uh issues across the board
you've got transracial you've got you've
got other kin you you've got people
mysticism's the root but but but i think
i i think ultimately it's just
there's a bunch of different
trans identity issues that have been
affecting us for a long time even
someone who wants to change their name
they're not happy with who they are
they're not satisfied with it it starts
very very small seeds i think uh for a
lot of people they feel like they're in
the wrong body
but
it could be for a variety of different
ways you know like rachel dolezal well
she's the wrong race i i think it's i
think it's related narcissism though
that this separation of the soul from
the body right like christianity has a
totally different understanding which is
that your soul and your body are
intricately related and once those two
are separated that's called death
and so i think you know if i'm an
atheist and i hear about neurolink and i
hear about transgenderism or whatever
you're born in the wrong body it
actually kind of makes sense like if
there is no god and your consciousness
can like be replicated and put onto a
hard drive like why not like you can you
can technically have a copy of you
living forever have you are you familiar
with other kin
uh isn't that like when you think you're
an animal or something they think
they're mystical animals yes so they're
you know it's like it's not necessarily
mystical animals for a lot of these
people they say they're like you know
owls you know or whatever or wolves or
they'll say they're like part owl part
cat or things like that but for some
people they think they're dragons they
think they're uh you know wyverns or
however you pronounce it yeah they think
they're mystical creatures that don't
even exist and so that's why i think
identity issues are are well beyond just
transgender i think we've been seeing
this on the internet for a long time
people have maybe narcissism or however
you want to explain it separated their
internal self from their physical self
that to me i think
is
maybe there's there's there's something
within people that uh you know they can
they can fathom the concept at some
point but you need some kind of catalyst
to make it more pronounced and i think
the internet is that catalyst an
opportunity for people to enter a space
where they can exist as something
different at least in facsimile well
where so you know right now you can go
you can put on the oculus and i did this
a while ago man i'll tell you during
lockdown when it first started and we
were in jersey i went on my deck i put
on the oculus and i was on google maps
and i was walking around all these
different places here's the crazy thing
before we even moved here
i went to harper's fair and i like
walked around to see what it was like
and go into the sea and everything like
that
but then there was also these chat rooms
and they're really interesting where you
can walk around and you can create a
digital character for yourself and i
make the joke that people walk around
like carrots because there were some
people that had like strange like
rutabaga bodies like they wanted to be a
rutabaga man and that's and for me i'm
kind of just like whenever i play these
games i have like a default avatar
because i don't care about what this
thing is you know what i mean like i'm
me and to me i'm just playing a video
game but to some people they go in and
they're like this is my chance to create
something that i would rather be
i suppose
the real issue might be people just
don't like their lives and they think
the grass is always greener one of the
things that really bothers me is when i
hear from people they say if only i had
money then i'd be able to do thing yeah
and i always tell these people like
that's not true
at all ask anybody who runs a business
having money
does not guarantee you the ability to do
anything some people are like i wish i
could start a successful youtube channel
but i don't have the money and i'm like
dude i had a phone all i had was a cell
phone when i started it and then when i
started doing commentary it was just a
gopro and they're like why don't you
have a gopro but you have a phone dude i
know you have a phone not everybody does
fair point
so spend you can get cheap phones with
cameras on it you can start somewhere
you can get a webcam for 15 bucks i
understand there's a base level you need
a computer or something a phone can do
all of it really but people would always
say to me with all of these resources at
their fingertips if only i had money
people seem to think if only i was x
then i would i would be finally be happy
and i'm just like if you're not happy
with yourself
you know
you're not going to find it chasing
after some mythical dragon beast or
you know truth be told video games are
fun
if i you know when i play the you know
when i when i use the oculus i don't
really it's fun
you know and it's going to be really fun
when they create you know they have
better vr haptic feedback i don't know
if i'd ever want to get neurolink but it
is tempting to be able to play video
games where you can actually like
experience flight and stuff like that
but
maybe the issue is there's too many
people who are more weak willed and
would rather live in the fake reality
where they can feel good all the time
and they would wither away and die if
they did
yeah i just i have a real aversion to it
all i i really think that like
any time you start to mess with your
brain where like the idea that someone
could upload thoughts to your brain or
download your thoughts like that's kind
of freaky to me and that's at the core
of neural like and if you look i have a
tesla i love it it's it's a great car it
goes zero to 60 in three seconds i don't
care about the environment if it didn't
go through zero to six three and three
seconds i wouldn't have it
but but if you look at this ecosystem
that elon musk is setting up right with
knurling spacex starlink and tesla like
it's all in the cell phone what is that
is that part of star wars cell phone
it's coming he's coming out the
satellite phone that's hooked up to
starlink so he he'll have a whole
ecosystem
and we don't even know does he have a
payment processing system i mean i know
he would help found uh paypal but
that is pretty intense like you would
put one guy and then i don't know and
then what's the other question like if
he gets to mars is that his now
yeah i think it'd be pretty cool you're
gonna defend it i guess let's go to
super chats if you haven't already smash
that like button smash that like button
now subscribe to this channel share the
show with your friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member we have
a members only segment coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m it will be published
let's read what you guys have to say
sean hirschberg says hey guys remember
when alec baldwin killed a woman oh yep
i do remember when he killed the woman
yeah
you guys remember when alec baldwin
killed him yeah that was what's going on
with that i don't know i mean where is
that court case
yeah why is it even arrested that's
right yep
green blue says ian is probably sick
from that raw aloe drink is that yeah he
was drinking some like aloe vera thing
the other day
yeah because it was really bitter yeah
huh yeah i don't know
all right
mike rader says theory joe biden is not
releasing the migs to ukraine because if
he does putin releases blackmailed dirt
on hunter and the big guy receiving
payment from the first lady of moscow
what's the likelihood
man i remember that narrative when they
were like what does putin have on trump
and now we're really coming into the
what does putin have on biden
isn't it all out there
a lot of it's out there i mean truth be
told this is more plausible
what does putin have on biden that is
definitely true yeah all those financial
dealings like we only have scratched the
surface on that
no he's just just a good guy what are
you guys talking about
man come on man what a what what
says tim just wanted to let people know
that there is a red flag law proposed
for kentucky sb 278 and that two a
loving kentuckians should contact their
state reps to let their voice be heard
definitely yeah
all right
vosh says are you kidding tim half of
hollywood still thinks he's innocent in
reference to jesse smilet getting work
in hollywood that's fair point yeah
they're gonna they're gonna put him on a
reality show and it's gonna make money i
mean we we joked that we should do a
short film called the jesse smallett
story where we reenact cinematically
like what happened and hire jesse to do
it and it's funny because we say we said
we joke because we know having jesse in
it would it would make money you'll get
clicks
and then i'm thinking about i'm like
they've got to be thinking the same
thing yep you don't got to like the guy
but you want to watch them and you want
to make money yeah correct yeah would
you watch the justice millett story
shameless i already know it but would
you watch it i would i would i i liked
it so lifetime i like to believe i
wouldn't but if it came down to it
there's no chance i might so
the batman comes out oh boy with robert
pattinson and i'm like i don't care to
see it really we love it and then we
ended up going to see it i didn't like
it
but i'll tell you this
if like lifetime announced the jessie
smilette story i would be sitting there
with popcorn i'd have chips and soda
everybody would be gathered around and
we'd be ready to go the moment we're
like it's starting everyone shh
you know everybody would want to see it
yeah wait wait wait what would a jesse
smell it lifetime movie look like it
would be like he comes back to town he
falls in love no
no but lifetime's the woman's network no
but you know what i mean like yeah for
tv movies yeah but it would be funny to
have like a women's movie about jesse
you know yes
it would be like the week leading up to
the attack yeah yeah and then it would
be like the cops would all be like we're
gonna frame him yeah that's the dramatic
they're like planting evidence he's like
i'm being set up don't you see it i
gotta i gotta i'm gonna warn the uh this
isn't like a major spoiler uh i'll warn
the audience though if you want to know
our opinion on the the batman film um i
mean i'm only speaking for myself here
but
it's uh the arc is that batman learns to
use his platform responsibly that was
the story is that the most successful
i thought so because at the end when
he's talking again spoilers at the end
when he's talking to the villains they
go i am vengeance which is what he said
and he's been so irresponsible with his
platform and what he's been doing in
public and he has to channel his
celebrities that's a productive way it's
when uh and again spoilers for those who
haven't seen spoilers so i'm gonna wait
a few seconds after i say spoilers and
now i'm gonna say it so earmuffs it's
when uh catwoman says to batman because
she doesn't know he's bruce wayne that
bruce wayne is just another like white
privilege that's a big part of it well
that's my that's exactly that works into
my point though like yes the question he
has to use his platform responsible he's
just a rich white male and he's never
thought about you know why i'm annoyed
people like i wouldn't say that the
batman is like insanely woke but it is
because white privilege is a psychotic
manipulation and lie that's true so as
soon as they they entertain it as a
concept in a film as if it's a true
thing that exists
you're dealing with
cultish propaganda let me explain to
everybody majority privilege exists
attractiveness privilege exists age
youth privilege exists there's a lot of
bias i own up to it you know that all
will have
and the reason why
you know i say white privilege is a lie
is that white privilege only exists in a
country with a majority white population
and try going to other countries and
they'll just be like they have a word
for you they have a special word for you
in many countries referencing you as a
you know foreign white person
white privilege
extends only as far as the cash in your
pockets and the cash of these countries
so it's
you know you how about we just
remove race from it it's wealth
privilege
which is basically everything privilege
yep
all right let's see we got here heavy
duty says anybody gonna talk about how
us lower class citizens are being
cheated out of our tax returns by the
irs finding mistakes on our returns
yup
that's how it goes man
the the everybody knows man the poor
stay poor the rich get rich
that's how it goes
everybody knows
all right jacob siebert says
hey tim and cast i would suggest getting
nigerian dwarf goats because they're a
lot easier to handle i would also
suggest a herd dog like a blue healer
and some other large breed to scare
coyotes my personal experience
um
luke uh rosie was on the show the other
day and uh we were talking about goats
he said full-size goats what do you get
like a gallon of milk per day yeah and
he's like if you want to drink milk then
get it and i'm like i don't know if i
want to drink that much milk man
and he said i'll help you out bro yeah
well he was saying the dwarf goats have
like six percent milk fat which is great
for cheese but that might make you fat
and i'm like
considering how many people we have i
think making cheese is like the right
way to go yeah bro i don't know how to
make cheese also if it hits the fan
getting fat off the food you have it's
not the worst problem yeah
well i'm excited for the stuff we're
building we're uh i thought you're gonna
say i'm excited for it to hit the fan i
was like
maybe we uh
the good news is i think the patio that
the the truck drove over the other day
we're gonna be okay yeah we can just
clean it off yeah so we were worried
because they just laid the epoxy and
then pressing dirt into it would push it
into the glue and you have to sand it
off but it looks like for now we're not
entirely sure some of it has come off
but not in the deepest area so otherwise
they gotta sand the patio it's gonna be
a disaster it's gonna suck yeah if you
want a full-size goat my family used to
have french alpine goats which were
really good really solid adorable babies
and a lot of milk milk yeah i mean what
about a cow i like combo oh yeah cows
are awesome how many gallons do those
produce i'm not sure
i assume they're a lot more difficult to
maintain but then what do you do with
the baby cow you got to get the cow
pregnant so do you like ask some dude to
bring his bowl over yeah i think that's
good you know they're like you put up a
sign saying like cow seeking bowl call
this no it's like a dating app
i guess like or do you bring your cow to
the bowl and the bowl like you know yeah
gets down to it then you bring the cow
back and then you get milk i'm sure they
have ways to do it i'm hearing from
google.com the website that uh
most dairy cows are milked two to three
times per day on average a cow will
produce six to seven gallons of milk per
day
yeah whoa whoa one cow will make six to
seven gallons per day yeah yep that's
what i'm reading this is from google
whoa all right like goats a little
better oh this is so here's the second
result so i'm getting even deeper into
my investigative research um it says
milk production per cow has more than
doubled in the last 40 years in the us
the average dairy cow produces more than
7.5 gallons of milk per day it's crazy
yeah goats are good compromise
all right our valeria says if the us
immediately started on an accelerated
program to build nuclear power plants
with the aim of providing 25 of the
country's power what are your thoughts
on the economic effects can we get free
of saudi oil yes i certainly think so
and we should i'm a big fan of nuclear
power especially the the newer
generations what do you think about
nuclear i love it i mean i look i've
seen chernobyl i mean
it's incredible what happened there but
that was all basically corruption
nuclear power
today we i don't think we've built a new
nuclear power plant in america since
like the 70s right or am i
misremembering that it's right
unfortunately we've got such better
technology now than in the 70s and we
haven't really had any major
catastrophes here in america yeah um
like three mile island no deaths yeah no
deaths nothing really nothing chernobyl
yeah
all right sean l says former army intel
collector here most news outlets are
very wrong read the military might of
russia china versus the u.s they
overstate their capabilities and
understate ours most people have no idea
how strong we are nukes are the issue
i agree i think the u.s is strong and i
think there's probably a lot of weapons
the u.s has that we don't know about i
also think the u.s is split between
local cultists and
you know regular people and that's going
to cause very serious problems i think
that's going to cause various serious
problems you know on the battlefield if
you end up with you know maybe not maybe
people who know better than i are going
to be alive we don't you don't have time
to think about that so it's just you
know fight and survive and get the
mission done but
i think when people start
seeing the world completely differently
from each other it'll cause very serious
problems
carrie my girl says justice with jesse
is the new show lol
yeah that's great justice with jesse
let's do it yeah there's there look
sheamus there are so many cartoon
opportunities for you on this one i know
i know look it's about narrowing down
what i'm going to focus on what's a good
like what's a good conspiracy film like
a whodunit
you have like a jessie smallett who done
it where he's trying to figure out who
framed him who actually framed him yeah
who framed jesse smalling no it's a
really good question that's a really
good question
we may never find the real hoaxer i i
don't uh i don't know
yeah
it was jim
very angry citizen says couldn't take
living in philadelphia anymore crime is
up quality of life is down filth
everywhere
as of 11 40 41 a.m today i'm a west
virginia resident just outside of
morgantown sent lids my resume god bless
you all congratulations on escaping
philadelphia we were on the other side
of the river and it was just brutal man
men
yeah these cities have fallen apart
javi j says smilet out on appeal but
kane velazquez was denied bail what an
upside-down timeline we are living in
who is that i don't know who that is he
is the guy who went out and um took
revenge on the person who assaulted his
child uh yes the former mma fighter yep
yep joshua bro says
jesse is out on bail pending the appeal
is it quite possible the appellate judge
issued a harsher sentence when he is
found guilty again the system wants
people to shut up and take it i bet this
is a bad idea for jesse
i think jesse is an egomaniac sociopath
and that the reason he was screaming i'm
not suicidal was because he was planning
on killing himself so they had to
restrain him to a bed with straps
because he would want to harm himself to
create a legacy of that it was a
conspiracy the whole time nobody will
believe it he's an egomaniac and a
sociopath and he's also really dumb
really dumb really dumb
mitso plick says
taco bell is to mexican food what
strawberry candy is to eating an actual
strawberry
yeah
that was like a lawsuit recently i read
about where some guy sued pop tarts or
something how dare you because he was
like it said strawberry but there's no
strawberries in it what and then the
judge said something like i don't think
any reasonable person would look at
what's on the box and assume it's a
strawberry
yeah
well it might not be real strawberry but
sometimes just what you want
i mean to be fair it does literally say
the word strawberry true technically it
does wait there are actually strawberry
like preserves in it
i don't i think that probably is
flavored i don't know i don't know we
can look it up i'm curious ian crossland
with a super chat saying sheamus please
make oh donald's in freedom tunes and
make the o'donald's worker an ethnic
irish guy so i don't know
he's an ethical irish guy oh no such
thing yeah oh
i can't believe
that you wouldn't beat me by a chance i
was pretty good right is that what
you're gonna say yeah i mean she beat me
too
i was actually deciding whether or not i
would malign an an entire group of
people based on their ethnicity uh but
before i could make that decision lydia
you're welcome
ian yeah but lydia's irish right yeah
yeah yeah that's allowed
yeah i knew there's a reason i didn't
trust her so ian is asking about owns
which harkens back to mcdonald's which i
i mean me it's possible that this
particular mcdonald's family was
scottish but mc is irish as the as the
super chat above testifies from ryan m c
cafferty
would you get sued if you made a burger
place called oh donald's because i
totally want to do it now that's yeah
it just depends what the logo looks like
it'll be a golden o
yeah
a big o yeah i don't know i almost want
to do it just because it'd be funny
it would be really funny let's do it or
at least like get the logo done yeah
what can we do colonel papa
oh donald's yeah it just makes all i
like it i'll tell you what my idea for a
restaurant is
so you know you go to panda express you
like walk up and you're in line and they
have you go there a lot don't you no i
don't at all so uh but you know you go
in and you're in line like and chipotle
you go in line and they have all the
food yeah my idea for a restaurant is
they have it's it's like panda express
because they have like the different
kinds of food the orange chicken or
spicy beef or whatever they have but
this place has orange chicken chicken
tikka masala and pot thai ooh so you go
there and they have those three things
and then maybe other sides because that
because those i think were like the top
three grubhub ordered items or something
so i was like
do one restaurant that serves those
three things then you and all your
friends could go there and you walk up
and you're like i'll do the orange
chicken they put in the thing you get
rice and all of it served with rice
anyway yep so it's like there you go man
i think i'd rather go for chicken tikka
masala be honest that's what i'm all
about that's my idea for a restaurant
although i really really would love to
have like a little fast food burger
joint
just like maybe like a little sit-down
place we'd do the quick burgers and you
know some fries oh donald's oh donald's
yeah
mcpools
you definitely get sued if you did that
if you put mc in front of yourself so
here's the question what if your last
name was actually mcdonald's and you
wanted to open a restaurant i don't
think you could yeah yeah to be honest
there was there's a hot dog place in
chicago i used to go to call donald's
though yeah yes yeah we used to go there
when we were in the city oh yeah yeah
delicious delicious yeah it is a really
good place to be honest
um all right ken says russian ruble is
up almost 54 percent so much for the
economic warfare but you won't hear that
in the mainstream media russia has a
massive stockpile of gold world
abandoning usd as a reserve currency
yup why would they do that buy what you
gotta buy now before it's too late yeah
all right let's grab some more
padre more mortalis says
remember that by the mexicans defeating
the french it helped prevent the french
from helping the confederacy therefore
helping the union win the civil war good
holiday to celebrate in the u.s oh yeah
cinco de mayo
that's right it's a great holiday
roberto lara says i was going to check
occupy democrats if they're praising
jesse guess they blocked me on facebook
and twitter wow so welcoming real facts
so honest yeah yep it blocks a lot of
people i guess on special noob says tim
timmy timothy please oh please name the
next rooster of chicken city dwayne the
[ __ ] johnson oh my god
yeah that's a good one that is pretty
good
i saw one earlier i was watching the the
chicken
feed over there oh yeah and someone said
uh cluck norris oh i like yeah
i thought that was pretty good well the
id the the original idea we had was that
all of our original chickens have
regular names and their last names are
bird puns
so we've got sarah avenberg we have uh
roberto beaks and he's the father of all
of the babies so basically every new
baby is a beaks part of the family so
roberto junior beaks then we have
vanessa peckingham
margaret hatcher that was brilliant i
was
that was very good margaret hatcher that
was brilliant and uh carol cluck
um
my one of my favorites is those katarina
kuritsa
yeah i like russian bird russian for
chicken ah yeah the name is catherine
chicken that's cute we just literally
called her chicken i think it's great
yeah no it's very good
look it works yeah that's right and now
we have i think downstairs right now 24
babies
so many yeah because we also had some
delivered
yeah and then we've got so cute
34 incubating
so out of the 22 incubated we did the
first incubation uh only 12 actually
made it
some of them appeared to not be
fertilized and one of them stopped
developing halfway through yeah it's uh
my wife and i we to keep our kids busy
during covet and also we were kind of
worried the world's gonna fall apart we
got a bunch of chickens and it's
devastating like when we did i think we
hatched six
and only three came oh man
uh it was just devastating because you
just wait and wait and wait it's a fun
fun little hobby though you know the sad
thing is though
you you really should not expect to have
chickens and treat them like pets that
you care about to be honest no because
we've got uh you know we care about our
chickens we love our chickens but
the uh you can't really have a bunch of
girl and boy chickens you can't do it so
we have roberto roberto jr and they have
to be retired after the boy's dormitory
which means they're going to go off to
other property and they're going to live
with all the boys because you you really
just can't have all these babies that
are being born the boys once they get to
a certain age off to the boys dorm yeah
because all the roosters can live
together i am really really excited for
when we unleash like 50 fully grown
roosters onto the property to just like
graze
and i'm i'm wondering what you know
predators would think because roosters
are they're mean yeah and you know a fox
could take one rooster for sure
but not 50 not 50.
yup just imagine the fox is like
crawling through the tall grass seeing a
rooster thinks it's all hens he doesn't
know he's gonna well he just he's the
one rooster and he's like i'm gonna eat
this this this you know
foul and then all of a sudden he jumps
for it and you just hear like all this
insane
and they all just run in and they're
jump kicking it and scratching it and
pecking it
and then the roosters eat the fox we
need a chicken uh cartoon series like a
chicken cartoon series they have one i
think chicken yeah they can't
actually they um they went to this guy
named kent oh i know
it's an anime no ken's pretty cool so
funny ken's pretty cool we love kent
yeah so we we do like uh we we have
cartoons in our vlog periodically and
some of them are just like you know the
chickens doing chicken stuff
yep
jc says read no winter lasts forever a
vigilante thriller about mass shootings
by jonathan epps oh interesting
interesting
cd says hello from scotland can confirm
mcdonald's scottish and mcdonald's irish
sheamus what are your thoughts on the
statements of pope francis today and the
consecration of russia and ukraine on
march 25th that's a good question so i
heard about the consecration of russia
and ukraine on march 25th what does that
mean that's very beautiful so he's going
to consecrate russia and consecrate
ukraine um
i can't really give any more details
than that he
i i didn't really hear i didn't hear his
statement from today you may have you're
also catholic so i didn't i didn't hear
the statement but that's there's
something big about consecrating russia
ukraine it's all you're related i'm
sorry consecrating russia to god and
it's all really like the fatima
appearances and um
yeah basically uh mary told those three
little kids that saw her
that if uh that the po or the church
needed to consecrate russia to
god and if he didn't that russia would
spread her arrows
all throughout the world and
never happened yeah it's interesting so
this is interesting because this is a
little beyond my pay grade but there's
discussion over whether russia was
consecrated under john paul the second
because there was a consecration of the
world that we were sort of told as a
consecration of russia but it's argued
that to consecrate something is to set
it aside so yeah but it so that that's
part what is it what does it mean is it
a special thing for russia it's good for
russia or what it's like isn't it let me
double check but i believe it's the
consecrate russia to mary's immaculate
uh heart yeah it's basically saying like
i don't even know what consequence it's
kind of like a a better blessing it's
like a blessing and a dedication like
you are now going to be serving
yeah oh god well all right then
all right alex says tim i've had enough
banning elote is the last straw cancel
chicago right yeah we were pissed we
would go to the we would go to venom
park that's where we would skate at
tennis court we'd skate in there and
then this like working class dude you
know probably an immigrant or something
he's coming up with a hard honest day's
work and he says young
young friends i have come to bring you
delicious corn with mayonnaise on it and
we were we would run up and we'd be like
throwing money at them because it's good
it's really good and and it was a
service provided to us that we were that
we appreciated and then one day they
stopped showing up they also had these
little like um
orange wheel looking things i don't know
what they're made of and they had uh
yeah so they had like different kind of
snacks i think they might have had pork
rinds too
yeah it's like orange crunchy things
that look like wheels that sounds good
and like we would get corn i'm hungry
some people would just go for the corn
in the cob
and then they you know put all the stuff
on it and you just eat it i like that
preferred yeah put in the cup and it's
just it's crazy to me that they they
took that away from us
you know you know you know what started
happening then ice cream trucks started
coming oh so we went from eating corn
good for you to ice cream better for you
man
man that ice cream guy was crazy though
true story the ice cream guy who'd come
to the park didn't know what money was
totally serious
yeah a weird thing happened where
someone it was like a dollar for an ice
cream cone someone went up to him it was
like i only got 80 cents is that enough
and the guy was like he didn't speak
english she was like yeah and then the
kid put the money into it he was like oh
thank you and then he went told
everybody like i just gave me 80 cents
he said it's okay and so people were
like okay so then people went up like
how about 50 cents and he was like yeah
and he would take it give him the cone
yeah and we were like and then one day
people realized like i'm going to offer
him something else and someone gave him
like a bike peg they walked up and they
had it in their hand and they found it
in the trash and they were like here
they put in his hand and he gave him an
ice cream cone and then somebody people
were like what
so then people would give him hands of
like handfuls of wood chips what they
would give him like shattered bits of
plastic and he would accept it true
story serious it was weird and then one
day he showed up and someone tried
giving him wood chips from the
playground and he was like no
and then
inside the machine was a dollar taped to
like the side
and he would look at and point out he
got smart
yeah it was really weird it was really
really weird yeah south side it's very
very odd
i don't know strange stories man strange
stories
all right let's see
laura t says please cover the d.a
dropping the charges against the lefty
security guard matthew doloff who shot
lee keltner what's that about i don't
know i don't know
yeah no idea we'll have to look into it
i suppose yeah
all right raymond g stanley jr says tim
quote the two most important days in
life are the day you were born and the
day you discover the reason why mark
twain any thoughts on that at all
um what is it what is it what is it
meant to mean the reason why you were
born like your purpose in life yeah
something like that
i was born to complain on the internet i
suppose heck yeah
discovered that here we are 36 years old
it only took me
uh you know 20 some odd years 28 years
figured out
yep perfect
glycerin goes says coming from your
keene and emmons podcast about cuties
i'm reminded of the beginning of brave
new world do you think we're heading in
that direction where taboos are being
broken for the sake of it
i feel like there's more taboos than
ever yeah yeah i don't know about
breaking it for the sake of it i think
people want they want to play life on
god mode
like video games
they're tired and it's a it's a big
mistake you ever ever play you guys have
played video games i imagine of course a
little bit not extensively so you know
let's say you're playing fallout 3 one
of my favorite games ever well on your
playstation you can play the game as
defined by the parameters of the game so
you find weapons you go on missions you
win the game on a computer however you
have access to what's called console
commands where you can basically spawn
objects cheat you can do whatever you
want
and after a while of playing the game
you're like i would like to do things i
can't normally do and have the game be
easy so you make yourself invincible or
you make yourself bigger or you give
yourself infinite weapons but the game
becomes boring fast because there is no
game when you have access to anything
and everything you want that's true so i
wonder if what might actually happen is
that when people go into the metaverse
and they get to experience a virtual
world they can do anything they say it's
boring well isn't there a line like that
in the original matrix
where he says something like the
original matrix
the human brain rejected it they needed
struggle and conflict and strife because
when it was perfect people just reject
it and that's probably it it's boring it
gets boring yeah i remember when i was
uh
a youngin i discovered debug mode for
sonic the hedgehog if you just press the
controller certain ways you could create
whatever objects you want and the game
got very boring very quickly yes like
there's no there's nothing to play for
i think a lot of people really want us
to open up o'donnell's yeah oh donald's
oh donald's someone said oh don else you
know what
the change you want to see in the world
what are you guys opening up i'm gonna
open a burger shop called sheamuses what
what you can't do that to me and the
funny thing is like i gotta be honest
sheamus it'll it will be hard for people
to like figure out pronounce it it's
true like that c misses why don't i go
there i know but it'll be like
s-e-a-m-u-s-e-s
dude when i was a young let me tell you
another young story i had uh i uh was
competing in a high school film festival
and you know my name's been butchered
really bad but uh i got
the announcer referring to me as
seamstress copland when i won an award
stream
i was like well you know what that's
just it's
my burden i had a friend named sean
s-e-a-n yeah and we had a
substitute teacher who came in was doing
roll call and she was like scene and
then everyone laughed
it's like
he raises his hand dude i knew someone
who's whose name was genre i suppose you
could say should have been sean it was
spelled s-e-a-n but like he and his
family pronounced it scene
yeah
that must have that must have confused a
lot of people too that's annoying you
got it you think it's a joke right like
no actually it's seen yeah jeez
dasher says world war iii will be called
the great oil war if the saudis switch
from selling the oil from us dollars to
the chinese yuan it will create more
chaos than world war ii but only to
china
so it's just like
they'll still be selling you know oil
for dollars except to china
once that happens yeah china's currency
is instantly stronger and then
international investment can move in for
china way more so the amount of value
china will gain from that one move and
the amount of uh the amount of value
that the u.s dollar will lose from that
one move is is massive so
buy it while you can before it's too
late i suppose
but i think uh
in inflation is on the way all right
we'll get one more brand dizzle says
name the restaurant seamuses
as a mermaid singing a siren song yeah
of course that's what i usually do just
just be natural there you go all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com and be a member so
that you can watch the members only show
that is coming up around 11 or so p.m as
we publish it as a member you're helping
support all of our journalists so it's
greatly appreciated you can follow the
show at tim cast irl basically
everywhere except tick tock we were
banned there you can follow me at tim
cast tara you want to shout anything out
yeah no i this was a great time i really
enjoyed the conversation you guys keep
me on my toes and uh no i i i have a
bunch of family friends from back home
who are texting have been texting me
this whole time so yeah
this is great awesome cool man yeah it
was awesome having you on i'm really
looking forward to the discussion on the
after show i want to maybe get more into
yeah
yeah i think that's awesome also i want
to issue a correction here i said this
maybe i'm being a little pedantic with
myself and i sort of touched on it but
with the creation of souls i was
discussing about sex as procreative and
creating souls of course as catholics we
believe god creates souls so i don't
want to mislead people about the
teaching there um i want to make this
point you guys should definitely check
out freedom tunes we're going to be
releasing a cartoon tomorrow
i'm going to describe it very dryly but
it's just basically on how world war ii
nostalgia is constantly being thrown at
us over the years to encourage us to
fight new wars and we continually fall
for it for whatever reason i hope we
don't this time thank you very much for
watching and we'll see you on the after
show very cool i saw a suggestion in the
chat for jesse pullett for one of the
chickens which i think is a great name
please keep sending me all your
suggestions you guys can send me your
suggestions for chicken names over on
twitter at sourpatchlits and on
mines.com as well i feel bad for that
chicken i can't do that dusty pull it
yeah it's adorable though i like it all
right everybody we will see you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you